is a real fat craving
baby cardi b's pregnancy cravings are
running wild the rapper was one happy
mama when she devoured a burger
i don't really eat burgers that much i
used to eat a lot of burgers when i was
younger like
teenager in my early 20s and now i'm
back at it again
and the main condiment she can't resist
is oh yeah
barbecue barbecue sauce barbecue mead
grilled meat
what else is on the menu a whole seafood
platter
i told my chef i'm hungry can you bring
me like just a plate
something simple he brought me all of
this
oh god these little garlic noodles they
look so simple but they taste so good
yup cardi chef whipped up the tasty dish
for the pregnant mama
some crab in the shell even put octopus
in here y'all know i love aquaponics
oh yes honey this isn't the first time
cardi was excited for some seafood
oh snap what is that is that a crab like
towel
the proud mom threw her daughter culture
a lavish third birthday party
complete with a crab leg tower wow
the 28 year old rapper announced she's
expecting her second child with husband
offset at the 2021 bt awards
since then cardi has been sharing her
pregnancy journey on instagram
like this video of baby number two
kicking
oh my gosh and these maternity photos of
her growing family
i love everything about motherhood in
2019
cardi opened up to et about motherhood
it means everything it's
it's like a feeling that it's
indescribable
it's like love joy it's a
switch a automatic smile
party was also lip-syncing to normani's
new single wild side
which she's featured on
[Music]
the dynamic duo released the
jaw-dropping music video and well
it's wild every other day
come take me out cardi couldn't help but
share her support
and excitement for the 25 year old
singer i feel like this is normani big
comeback and like i want you guys to
treat it
like it's her birthday like this is
literally her birthday
and like this song this everything is
amazing and i'm just so proud of her i'm
the support team okay i'm just here
like yay but um i'm so excited
you guys are gonna see like normani in a
different light oh my gosh i'm excited i
this is amazing